[Musique]
super lioran
la dernière née des stations d'hiver
d'auvergne offre ses 40 km de pistes
réparties sur les versants du clan du
cantal
elle offre aussi la tradition une
gastronomie bien particulier il n'est
pas une auberge qui propose aux
touristes de revivre l'ambiance
séculaire des burons ces refuges où les
bergers des monts d'auvergne près par le
célèbre fromage et dégustent à la fin de
l'estival intrus fan
[Musique]
la truffade c'est une vieille recette si
vous voulez la connaître alors faites
comme nous joignez vous aux convives et
du cantou
en revient à l'hiver l'hiver à tout
blanc sur les clochers de chez nous
je revois avec mes yeux d'enfant
réveiller dans le camp
le sait vous qu'on appelle dans le pays
alexis lé belge et alexis le berger oui
hein
le berger vous l'avez été combien
d'années oh vous savez je les fais une
partie de ma vie pour ainsi dire quoi
nous nous calons dindane ou louis berger
tout jeune a toujours oui comment ces
jeunes et puis après souvent lieu on
évolue et on est passés bouthillier et
puis à des armes armures rade après
vaches et quelles nouveautés vous êtes
je suis de l'autre côté du tunnel la
tête du tunnel yoran saint jacques
et oui ça fait plaisir alexis ii surtout
et d'un coït ou d'échanger des souvenirs
et oui et oui on se plaît de se
retrouver quoi puisque peut-être vous
avez fait le même métier et je lis connu
mais pas dans le même pays parce que la
hausse a soufflé un vous aidiez à
combien d'altitude on était à plus de me
remettre là haut sur le plateau alors ce
n'était pas toujours rigolo non les
jeunes ils en veulent encore à les
jeunes les jeunes aujourd'hui ça
n'existe plus vis en plus ce n'est plus
le même méthode de travail les mêmes
méthodes d'exploitation 40 ans ou jeunes
autre temps disons et on s'est modernisé
un petit peu voulu emmener les bêtas ya
les stars
oui disait que notre temps et notre
temps il fallait faire le chemin à pied
avec le troupeau 40 km est plus même
oui dans la montagne va sur les routes
et dans les montagnes à présent non
seulement vont mener les belges y met
les vaches elles ont vu non plus gros
match aller va se résumer par un oui les
vaches les va s'étendre le pas mieux que
le personnel voilà personne non plus ne
veut marcher à pied arrêtés on faith est
le bon temps quand même
j'étais le bouton aujourd'hui on est la
boule latifah et comment j'ai autrefois
dans les bureaux
cette bonne vieille truffaz vous en avez
mangé aussi où j'en ai mangé quand le
saison était finie on se rassembler dans
les bulles ah oui à ça et puis on se
raconter les souvenirs et on mangeait
les prévisions étaient là avant de
redescendre dans le pays a oui là là
c'était le c'était la finition là ne
voulait pas
rien traîner dans le bureau mais c'est
jean luc cyr si je pouvais raconter des
vieux souvenirs
mais on en aurait tous à dire en a
leurré 3 jarry mais enfin quand même il
y en a qui restent il y en a qui
l'inspirent brigade et on se rappelle au
mieux des bons souvenirs que les mauvais
heureusement
alors aujourd'hui on attend nos
parisiens qui eux aussi j'en entendu
causer de latifa ne me sens pas ce que c
est bon mal de lapland bas j'en sais
rien je l'apprécié voilà voilà
note pas l'hygiène hanif lol bon jour là
comme on n'en voit bien content de voir
que vous faites là dans le code et vous
qu'est ce que vous faites de bon la
hausse que ça a l'air bon la truffade
intrus fan c'est un bien simple sur des
pommes de terre bien rigoler avec de la
tome fraîche et de la crème de la tomme
le tome nous parce que c'est celle de
produits du lait caillé pressé que l'on
dont on se sert pour faire la forme du
cantal et vous mélangez avec homme ou
femme on mélange un bon coup de main et
vous faites une bonne truffe elle et
c'est la forme la table sa faune et sa
sli et ça vous donne une bonne une bonne
envie de vous mettre à table
pourquoi on l'appelle être fait parce
qu'il ya bien des années à la fin de
l'estivé les bergers les boutillier et
les vaches et se rassembler pour la fête
finale après steve et se rassembler pour
faire une truffade il avait la provision
et finissait les provisions il avait la
tome fraîche
il avait les pommes de terre et on
l'appelle la truffade parce que dans le
pays la pomme de terre s'appelle una
truffe et la truffe étant la pomme de
terre du pays et alors on faisait cette
cérémonie on avait parié rare chez les
vaches et les boutillier et l'éveil
hébergés ils se rassemblaient et il
faisait avec les bd boutillier qui était
en quelque sorte des manoeuvres éplucher
les pommes de terres les bergers faisait
la cuisine et les vaches et et l art
ensemble pour surveiller
afin de la fête on dégustait interligne
avec par ordre les vaches et ensuite les
boutillier et les bergers et on faisait
la fête ont mangé cette truffade qu'on
ne trouve qu'ici et à la fin on orsay on
s'amusait et en profiter un petit peu de
bons moments qui leur restait avant de
redescendre dans la vallée
et bien moi paris avant d'appeler la
reine de la pomme de terre
on doit vivre ce que la reine de la
truffade s'emballer
[Musique]